- Finland is one of the
most interesting markets
in the world for somebody like
me because I'm unemotional,
meaning marketing to me is
just whether it's outdoor,
or Google or Facebook or
Snapchat or Instagram or drawing
on a building or a flyer or television,
I'm just unemotional; I don't care.
I don't love digital, I
don't like technology.
I like attention because
if you have attention
then you can tell somebody
what you're about.
In Finland, per capita,
the usage of Instagram
and Facebook in comparison
to how much marketing money
is being put in there by
the companies in Finland
is one of the biggest
opportunities in the world.
The citizens of this country are using
these platforms tremendously.
The entrepreneurs are
building small, little things,
the problem is unlike America
where the entrepreneurs
are winning.
So in America, every big
company is in deep shit.
For real.
Like every industry including
Pizza Hut and Dominoes,
big trouble because they're
spending money on television
and outdoor and direct
mail and little startups
are spending it on Facebook
and things of that nature
and it's happened overnight.
(mumbling)
What happens here is
entrepreneurs start winning
in Finland and then they
realize how much it works
and they leave because the
market's not the biggest market.
So when they see how big
the arbitrage is on Facebook
they go to the Nordics, they go to Europe,
they go to the US.
They go get funding in
the US and start up.
What's that done is created a
very interesting environment
here in Finland, in my opinion,
which is the big companies
are wasting money on traditional
stuff that got them here.
The entrepreneurs are
spending money originally
but then leave.
You have to understand why
I'm so in love with Facebook
and Instagram right now.
It's a marketplace.
There is no floor.
When you buy an ad on Facebook,
if it doesn't work well
and you try to spend a
lot of money, it stops
because their most valuable
thing is the person's attention
and bad advertising is bad for them.
Whereas, when you run a
bad print ad or radio ad,
they'll take your money.
And so to me, there's
an enormous opportunity.
Influencers, I mean, when
I think about fast casual
or food space like I would
probably map all 5,000 people
that matter on Instagram
in Finland and pay them
to give awareness to your restaurants.
I think the arbitrage in this country...
That's why when you said all
locations here, I perked up.
I was like okay, they're
gonna be very interested
in what I have to say.
I would spend 90% of
your money on Facebook.
Yeah, and I'll tell you why
because it's a moment in time.
My energy is based on
resentment and regret.
I'm very famous in my circles
for building my dad's liquor
store in 1996 from three
to 60 million with no money
because I figured out Google.
But the true is it should've
been three to 200 million.
I didn't spend enough on Google.
Because marketplaces eventually correct.
Right now, I know for four
dollars to seven dollars
I can get in front of a
thousand people in Finland
on Facebook and they're paying attention.
In four years, it's gonna cost me 80
and they're not gonna be paying attention.
That's it; moments in time.
So not that I ever believe
spending 90% of any money
on anything is the right
idea other than if you're in
the real estate business,
if you're right about
the beach front property, in
that moment you should buy
all of it.
It's okay not to do other projects.
That's how I feel about
Facebook and Instagram right now
in this country.
- [Man] Is it because
the average digital spend
in Finland compared to average usage...
- Yes, that's exactly right.
And unlike other markets
where the entrepreneurs
and the venture capital-based
companies fill the pipe
and get the prices up, people leave here.
Got it?
That's the opportunity.
That's why I'm here.
- [Man] Almost makes me think
that now that we're talking
about the no pizza concept,
should we actually be
considering or creating
the no pizza concept
and just export the buying
form and then the product?
You can produce it almost
anywhere, but you would actually
have a comfy space.
You would just buy it
and consume it whole.
- The leap there gets more
logistically and operationally.
I think, at it's bare minimum...
Like for example, the 270 locations.
What's that called again, I apologize?
The first pizza place?
(mumbling)
So C-O, K-O-T-I.
What do you spend on marketing?
What do you spend your
marketing money on now
to make that company successful?
- [Man] How much is the spread now?
- [Woman] On TV?
- Anything, across the board, TV.
- [Woman] TV, out of home
advertising, both digital
and out of home.
- Yep.
- And then radio.
(people talking over each other)
- [Man] How much euros?
- Three million.
- Three mill.
- [Woman] Yeah, three, roughly.
- And how much does TV get?
- 40%.
- And then out of home?
- Ten, 12.
- And radio?
- Eight, ten.
- And then digital.
- Digital, 35.
- And within digital, what is it?
- [Woman] I can't give you an idea.
- No problem.
To me, what I've seen over and over again,
before I convince the
founder of the board to move
the big numbers, usually the
35% is where I focus first
because digital itself
has a lot of bad stuff
in the way that I think.
There's traditional digital
and there's 2018 digital.
Most of my clients and a lot
of what I see in the world
spended on programmatic
and search and banner
and not enough on social and influencer.
And then there's the question
of are you doing sales
or are you doing branding?
Because that's a whole mix in itself.
What's the ROY?
Is it a transactional
in-store foot traffic sale,
delivery sale?
How are you breaking up brand.
Such a confusion, I've been
surprised now going through it
the last ten years.
I'm surprised how many people
think they're marketing
but what they're doing is selling.
It's sales.
Everything is based on well,
it cost us nine dollars
on Google to get this ten dollar pizza.
We make three dollars
profit, that's not good.
What's the LTV?
And they're not thinking about the brand
or the long tail or the
arbitrage of creative
or all the other variables
that actually play out.
I don't buy Nike's because of
a sale, I buy it because it
won on brand and I think a lot about that.
And then how do you
replicate what you're...
To me, the biggest opportunity
for you is to figure out
how Facebook three-minute,
two-minute, one-minute videos
subsidize what you're doing on television.
Once you've figured that
out, I think you'd be stunned
by the ROY.
- Explain again.
- I think what you're doing on...
Well actually, let me take a step back.
On television, are you doing
what I see a lot of QSR
companies doing?
Are you doing promotional advertising,
or are you doing brand?
- Both.
- What would you say is the 50/50, 80/20?
What's your gut tell you?
- [Woman] Well, now recently
it has been let's say 75/25.
- Promotional.
- Brand.
- Brand, great.
So, you know, to me my belief
is that in this country
specifically that the
amount of actual consumption
of the commercial is far less
than the way it's reported.
That the math, I don't know if
you're using an internal MMM
or how you're scoring the
success of your television,
but the most sophisticated
scores of television
in the US and Europe and
other parts, they're making
too many assumptions of
consumption of commercials.
The reason they say it works
is just the shear amount
of money that they spend.
You know.
I had one friend, I asked
him to just turn it off.
I just didn't feel the effects of business
that much at all.
To me, I have a lot of clients.
I had a meeting in the US
and she says well, Gary,
you know I do this, and she
goes Gary, but it didn't work.
Digital didn't work, television worked.
I go okay.
I just know that that's not
true 99 out of 100 times.
So I said let's talk, like
I said, in the same way
like give me the details.
And she smiled, she's
amazing I like her a lot,
she smiled so I already
knew I was in good shape.
She said okay.
I go what were the results?
What did you do in the first?
She said, it didn't work.
I said, how do you know?
She said well in the
first quarter of this year
we did digital.
I go okay and she goes in
the last quarter we did TV.
So first I jumped on the fact
that liquor sales in the US,
50% of it is done in the fourth quarter
versus the first quarter,
but that wasn't even it.
I thought that was my a-ha.
That was nothing compared
to the next thing she said.
She said we spent 484
thousand dollars on digital
in the first quarter.
They spent 8.5 million on television.
It's very interesting how
people want to protect
what they know, or what got them there.
I think Facebook videos...
First of all, a couple things.
Here's what I don't like about television
and why I'm obsessed about Facebook.
First, I think more people, if
you spent ten million dollars
or a million, if you spent a
million dollars on television,
you spent a million dollars
on Facebook video ads,
I think that more people would
actually see the Facebook.
That's number one.
Like actually see it.
Number two, here's the
most important part,
there's a very big difference
between somebody who makes
150 thousand euros a
year living in Helsinki
and somebody who makes 42
thousand euros living in a suburb
of how they're gonna associate your brand
and what value your pizza brings to them.
The fact that television
only allows you one piece
of creative, versus the fact
that Facebook can target
very specifically and you're
able to make eight pieces
of creative, if you're 62 and you're 29,
I have a funny feeling your brand, Koti,
means something different.
Your television is just doing one message.
It's the flexibility of scaled context
is how I think about it.
Let me just finish this then
I'll let you jump into it.
If I ran a workshop and
said okay, let's talk about
the demographics and
psychographics of your customers,
we'd probably have seven
or eight meaningful groups.
Eventually it becomes too
small, but the first may be 18
to 23-year-old males, the
second one might be people
that make 80 thousand a
year, some may be in both.
But once you get to those
eight, if you make two videos
per those eight, now you
have 16 assets and if you run
your media, which I think is
more efficient on Facebook.
You see where I'm going,
how I spend that million
in a different way.
- [Man] Related question about the budget.
So one of the problems
that we econometric studies
about marketing efficiency
in Finland runs into
with digital is it's
hard to do digital a lot.
We have 95% brand awareness in Finland.
Our issue is ongoing into
areas where we would have
higher brand awareness.
Availability, opening hours,
group dynamics dictate
whether our marketing is efficient or not.
The shops not open, if it's too
far, the queues are too long
on a Friday night, there's
very little we can do.
Also, we sell to half of Finland.
So we sell to a lot of
nurses and taxi drivers
and unemployed people and what have you.
It might be an opportunity
from a segmentation
point of view, but the
point is how do you do
social media marketing a lot?
We know that if we spend 50K on it easily
it'll be efficient.
But how do we spend half a million on it?
How do we spend 1.5 million on it?
That's what it runs to.
If it's awareness, our logo
needs to be everywhere,
our message needs to
be heard, that's fine.
But we only have so many times of the week
when our market is going
to be tactically efficient
and we have 95% brand awareness.
- A couple things there.
So that's great, I appreciate it.
First of all, in a world where
you have 95% brand awareness,
if you're spending 75% of your
45% of your marketing budget
on TV brand, you're already broken.
Like period, you've already
wasted almost half your money.
Right?
If you really think about that.
You're doing 75% brand on 45%
of your overall allocation
on television in a 95% awareness
marketplace that's confined
like that, that's already
just a wrong strategy.
Number two, I would
argue, first of all, scale
is not an issue for
Facebook; it's just not.
You notice, this is a
very common question.
Facebook has more scale,
actualized consumption
in Finland, than television
does; actualized consumption.
Facebook, when you add Instagram
with it, has more scale.
You could, back to your
point, if you want to do,
which based on what I'm
hearing right now and obviously
I'm just picking up queues
here, already doesn't feel like
the right move for you,
based on those metrics
that you just fed me.
But you could spend an enormous
amount of your allocation
on Facebook, the problem to
your point, it's a smart point,
is at 50 thousand dollars
you may like the CPN costs.
At 400 thousand dollars,
they're gonna go up
and you're not gonna like them as much.
To me, when they're actualized,
and this is the most
important part of this
conversation, they're dramatically
cheaper than remnant television
because we're making,
again like I said, we're
making too much assumption
on what's actually being
consumed on that 30-second slot,
plus, back to my prior point,
the creative is not relevant
because you've got one vanilla message
for the entire country.
Even more exciting to me, to your point
and you picked up on it,
is if you're talking about
opening and closing and
things of that nature,
the number one most effective
thing I'm doing in the US
is running one-mile radius of Wal-Marts
and Dollar Generals and
Sonic restaurants, back to
your business, and Ruby
Tuesday's, back to your business.
When you get into one-mile
radius and things of that nature
you don't need to be wasting your dollars.
At the same level, you
know what's incredible?
The flexibility of a
platform like Facebook
is I think of it as day-trading,
versus long-term mutual
fund investing.
You're talking about very narrow things.
You could, back at home,
be turning the levers
based on all sorts of variables,
including if you're talking
about long lines and
things of that nature.
The amount of granular
flexibility that you can spend
your media based on the
realities of your day in
and day out business is pretty remarkable.
Including event marketing,
traffic behaviors.
I mean, pretty incredible granular stuff.
They're doing individual
marketing and I think
that's where it's all going.
They're in a different place
financially and sophistication
but that is where it's going.
I think getting it from
blunt marketing to as close
as you can get to that individual basis.
- [Man] Individual meaning
going towards the customer?
- They have a great advantage
that you and I don't have,
which is like everything
lives within their ecosystem.
They see every behavior.
That's something that
you're not going to be able
to get to but on the flip side,
if you're doing ten percent
of your transactions now
done by a mobile device
you're starting to pick up real data.
You're going to be able to do
some pretty remarkable things
and lapsed users and
things of that nature,
you could do some pretty great stuff.
- [Man] Once you start
talking more accuracy
like to predict.
How important is the creative part?
- It's the variable.
- [Man] Should we be spending
more money on creative?
- Yes.
- Okay.
(laughing)
- But here's the problem,
it's not fun for us
business people.
I don't like it.
I hate being at the
vulnerability of creative.
It sucks.
It sucks to spend 80 thousand
dollars, make something
great, and then it doesn't perform.
Unfortunately, it is
the variable of success.
One Facebook YouTube video
for Dollar Shave Club
created a billion dollar exit.
Where is the beef?
Just do it, MasterCard
priceless; those are real things.
The problem is, it's all
the same rules of television
apply, the problem is we
have so much more data
to see what's working and not working.
So we're holding the new
world to an accountability
that we don't hold the old world to.
- It's a question of loyalty?
- Yes.
- That's one of our things
that we got more loyalty,
we get the loyal customers to buy at times
when we have queues on that loan.
IE, when they buy seldom, they
always buy on a Friday night,
on a Saturday night, when
all the restaurants are busy
anyways so it's harder to sell more.
We get more loyalty maybe
we'll get them to buy
on a Wednesday night.
The other thing...
- The other thing
I apologize real quick before you move on.
That to me is another
argument for Facebook.
You're able to run more
Tuesday, Wednesday promotion
because what I love about it
is when you have flexibility
you can map it to the
reality of your business.
For you and I, what's
tough about some of these
bigger marketing things is
it's upfront and it's gone.
There's no flexibility.
Not only that, I'll tell
you what's really amazing
about your business is weather.
It's a huge variable.
So again, to me, when you
understand your business
you can be spending it on,
you know, this is rare weather
here so I'm very excited,
but I think one of the other
things to think about
is is the flexibility.
I agree with you, like the
Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday
thing, you know, is
super fascinating to me.
One, targeting those.
You have first party data now, right?
You have those ten percent.
Running them in Facebook and
Instagram to drive transactions
Tuesday through Thursday, or,
I don't know how you built
your app, or what the product
is, just direct messaging,
to me, you want 100% mobile
usage if you can help it.
You should incentivize it at all costs.
- [Man] Any other ideas on loyalty?
- Incentivize at all costs.
We're doing this for my
dad's liquor store now.
We're basically pricing
things fundamental...
We're basically forcing
you to give us your data,
meaning I think that you
guys have the ability.
I would look at your
highest profit margin items
and come up with Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday sales
predicated on them buying
that only if they do it
with the mobile.
I would just start jockeying your products
to force behavior to
get them into the system
because that data is more
valuable than the profit margin.
- Second question.
- Yeah, I forgot.
(laughing)
- [Man] From my experience,
Facebook is more brand
and Google is more transaction driven.
- I think that's right,
except we're starting to see
a lot more DR capabilities in Facebook for
the most sophisticated.
- Okay.
But you still suggest in
our case where we haven't
identified brand awareness
that we should still spend
90% on Facebook.
- Yeah.
- Why?
- Because I think that
it's clearly based on what
I'm hearing, the place that...
First of all...
- Compared to Google though.
- Yeah, there's a couple things.
- One, I think that there's two things
that's super interesting.
Again, let me answer.
This is intuitive and
let me break it down.
Number one, I think that
there's 95% brand awareness
and then there's 95% brand awareness.
There's assumptions here
of our brand awareness
that I'm sure are right when
they're at those numbers
but there might be a bigger
delta than we realize.
- I'll give you like 30
years, biggest pizza chain
in the country.
- Understood.
I believe that.
I think what's happened over
the last seven years, and this
by the way, I'm making this
answer based on Coca-Cola.
I think that no matter
how successful you are,
you're not more successful
than Coca-Cola in America
and I think when we looked at
their Gen Z and Gen X numbers
they were staggeringly
surprising because I think when
you start thinking about
a 25-year-old in Finland
you might be stunned how
little they've ever...
Now, they're gonna know it
because you've got a lot
of locations, I get it.
But they may not know it the
way you think they know it
is number one and then there's
contextual brand awareness.
One of the great things
about 95% brand awareness
is 95% brand awareness.
One of the terrible things
about 95% brand awareness
is 95% brand awareness,
meaning there's a lot of people
that have a certain point
of view on your product
that is entrenched.
- [Man] That they might
just know the logo.
- They're just entrenched.
I don't know, I'm shooting
so blind right now.
I'm trying to bring value.
But real quick right now, my friend,
just let me finish this.
Your ability to at scale, back
to the seven segmentations,
change perception to create
more percentage of wallet
and better LTV is far greater than I think
most people realize.
That's how big.
A lot of what I would
probably, if I was really deep,
a lot based on what I'm
hearing, we've had a very
unprecedented run with
Budweiser in America
these last 18 months after
14 years of declining
we've been able to turn it
around while all the trends
are going the other way.
Craft is exploding.
Against all odds and
it's been 100% based on
a lot of these theories.
One, moving them from
television to Facebook.
Two, tapping into relevance.
Three, they're starting to
do a lot of different skews
that we're tapping into
and it's psychology.
Military, baseball, we're
playing a lot of those
different things but I think all companies
can benefit from that.
And again, the biggest thing
that I want to make sure
that you guys understand
is it's just because I know
it's gonna go away.
That, to me, is that the
pricing is gonna go away.
- [Man] It's already gone in the UK.
A lot more companies are switching.
Our competition is that we're
300 but there are some like
11 or 1200 pizzerias in
Finland, which don't pay tax,
which is single entrepreneurial run.
Shady business.
They serve a pizza with
an up to 60% cost benefit
because they don't pay tax.
They procure their stuff from wherever.
They don't pay employer
costs and that kind of stuff.
They will sell the pizza
for 4.90, 5.90, 6.90.
The only way for us to
tackle that market is to
introduce a coupon
campaign where you can get
the rare pizza for 7.90, which
just about breaks us even.
That's the biggest market,
that's the biggest challenge.
We're against criminals and
tax evaders who at the prices
would never be able to
even pay for their cost,
not to mention a profit.
That's a fact.
And we need something there.
How would we use any engine
to be able to approach
the kinds of people who
elect to go to an illegal...
- I understand.
Have you guys debated a different brand
to attack that world?
Because I think the
danger that you'll go down
if you attack that world
is diluting the brand.
We've all been stuck doing that.
I've done it, all my friends have done it,
all my competitors have done it.
The dangerous thing that
you just set up in my mind
that I'm sure you're trying
to think through thoughtfully
is one, FSI's couponing dilute a brand.
Two, going there will
dilute everything else
you're doing where you have more margin.
I think one of the things
to debate is to rethink.
I know you're thinking about
the no and you've got a lot
going on here so I have a lot of empathy,
but it's very entrepreneurial
so that makes it
exciting for me.
For me, my natural intuition
is to go very far down
the path of creating a different brand
to attack that market
because I'd be too fearful
to completely collapse.
The amount of people
who've lost this game,
and much more sophisticated,
global QSR's have been
destroyed by seeing the
scale underneath them,
being seduced by that, going down there,
and then giving up
everything on the above.
- [Man] Are these coupons,
or annual coupon campaigns,
take sales up to an
injection of up to 34%?
- What happens with the
LTV of those people?
Do you have any sense?
- We don't, we can't...
- Soon you will.
- We can't differentiate
between who buys it but we
just know it's the pricing.
I'm just saying that.
- No, I get it.
- The base face value,
the base line for our
marketing in a previous study
two years ago was 86%.
So our marketing only
explains 14% of our sales.
Meaning that whether the shop
is open and where the shop is
and what have you, we can
deliver, how long the queues are,
it's so dominant that our
marketing only explains
about 14% of our sales, but
when we have a coupon campaign
we have an injection of 32, 34%.
Which gives you some kind
of an idea with how big
the challenge is with the price.
- I don't think it's a challenge.
I think it's a decision you
guys have made to pander
so short-term math.
That may make sense because
you might be selling the brand
to a PE, I don't know
what's happening here.
But that's no challenge.
I would argue that's the norm.
What you just described is
99% of the businesses I see
because 99% of the businesses
I see have to pander
to short-term math.
Whether it's the entrepreneur's
ambition to take cash
out of the system or Wall Street.
- How can we do it?
- Couple ways.
- In a modern way.
- Yeah, a couple ways.
- [Man] How to do it with paper couponing.
- So first of all, the first
thing I would to your point
I would inject immediately
making the next campaign
a mobile only coupon.
I would force through paper
over time into your own system
because you'll be able to do so much more.
I would literally use
paper, think about this,
this is funny.
By the way, talk about eating your own dog
food, literally yesterday
morning I approved a direct mail
piece, which I rarely do,
for my dad's liquor store
where it's only about getting them into
the mobile club card,
which is in your wallet.
You know the wallet app?
So I'm literally giving
the advice I'm taking.
So how often do you do that?
- We have the next one next
June, which we have decided
to do only digital.
- Digital.
- We drove the paper coupons
out of that campaign.
I don't know how much is
the media investment now
for the digital coupons,
versus together with paper.
- To me, getting them into
the mobile device and owning
all of the data is so
valuable that I would, again
depending on your finances,
depending on your long-term
finish line, I would be willing
to lose money to get them
in because once they're
in, you don't have to spend
all the money on paper or digital ads.
You're remarketing within yourself.
The reason I use the
wallet is I'm using an app
called Pop Wallet so the
club card is in their wallet
the way your flight, thin aired
stuff is, but it also gives
me the ability to text
message them and push notify.
You know, you get a push notification?
So I've amortizing down
my advertising costs
because I've got them in
the funnel and I've got
the first party data.
In essence, I don't give a shit.
Especially because it's my
family business for my dad.
He's gonna keep it until he dies.
So to me, if I could advertise
it over 20, 30 years, right?
I think the biggest piece of
data that I don't have sitting
in this room is the macro
long-term financial ambitions.
If you're not looking to
transact on that business, Koti,
in the next five years, I would
go so hard and spend so much
to just keep the lights on but
get all the first party data
in because back to 95%
and owning the market.
- [Man] I just wanted to
ask both of you and Gary,
isn't this also the
brand awareness problem?
With the USA we have the
competing against lethal pizzas.
Me, I'm a user, of course I was.
To me, no matter how green
you make it or how green logos
you use, and you should
have done recently,
my brand awareness is from 10 years ago.
You can't change it.
That brand awareness is
there and it's killing.
- [Man] We heard it already.
- Talk to me, you said
killing and you said was.
Talk it out.
Why were you why?
- Cheap pizza bad ingredients.
- Okay.
- But now you're not cheap
anymore because you have other pizzas
and you're trying to
make good ingredients,
but I'm putting you in
the same box as older guys
who are cheap pizzas, bad ingredients.
But you're not cheap and you look green,
but I don't know if you're
green. I'm not going there.
The brand awareness is
actually hurting you.
- To me, the biggest thing is...
- [Man] I agree with Gary.
- What excites me about
what you're saying for me
and as we're breaking this
apart is okay, how old are you?
- 32.
- Good.
I'm telling you right now, you
have no chance of getting him
on television commercials.
That's getting half your money.
- [Man] I don't have television.
The last time I saw TV was five years ago.
- You just have no chance.
Have you guys looked at
the OTT numbers in film?
It's over.
To me, that's exciting
because I'm like okay,
he's a 32-year-old dude who can afford it.
So we need to make contemporary creative.
First of all, you have a very big asset.
Him in a video being like motherfucker,
I know what you think, but
let me tell you the truth.
That has a way better
chance of changing his brand
perception back to the 95%
what's good and bad about it.
My intuition, again as I'm
building blocks here of knowledge
and context, it feels super right to me
where I'm going and I'll tell
you why because it's working
for everybody because what I
think everybody is struggling
to comprehend is that it
happened, not that it's happening.
It happened, it's over.
Back to like digital
coupons, it scares me too
because programmatic banners,
pop-ups, all that stuff,
that can get very ugly.
I have the same scrutiny
of programmatic as I do
about television.
Do people actually see it?
(people talking over each other)
Forget the photo, this is business.
This is much more interesting.
This is what they care about.
- [Man] The challenges that we are facing
the past three, four years
have been really fast growing.
We came from a bankruptcy
into being the shiniest
of the block.
- That's great.
And why did that happen?
- There are several reasons.
You get lost on the way how
much is a lot because we've
doubled the sizing within three years
with the same locations.
- Locations or revenue?
- Actually fewer locations.
- Great.
- So doubled the sales.
- Why?
Average ticket sale?
- Both.
Traffic and average ticket sales.
- Also the whole green
sign on the restaurant.
- That's great.
- I mean you get also
lazy in thinking that
the formula got us there.
- Of course, success is
the biggest vulnerability.
I get it.
- [Man] I think that we
feel that we won't double it
with the same medicine.
So I mean this ingredient
already so that the marketing
plan that we'd been discussing
about for the coming year
or the rest of the year is
I think we need to break
the formula again.
- Let me tell you...
- [Man] This great element,
but this has been...
- Let me tell you one thing that's great
about this world as well.
Unlike a lot of other
worlds, you don't have
to do it upfront.
What I would recommend is
that's what's so great,
the media can be spent very, very targeted
and at low numbers.
You can start with ten and
12 and 19 thousand dollars
for that week.
And really what's great
about your business
unlike a lot of CPG's
is you're gonna see it.
You do have that; you do
have your foot traffic
and the average sale data.
- [Man] So question, organizing
if you go and you change
media agency as your partner
with social media advertising
versus doing it yourself.
- Preference is always yourself.
- [Man] Can you do it with a media agency?
Would you go like 100%...
- You can, but I would highly recommend...
I mean, the reason why my
agency is having so much
success is because it's
independent and it wants to
buy brands and businesses.
To me, the answer is you can.
First of all, somebody here
has to know what the fuck
they're doing because if the
judge isn't knowledgeable,
whether it's internal or
external, you're vulnerable.
So I would say that's number one.
And I would argue for
both you two, at least
from what I'm gathering
here, need to spend 20 hours,
I mean it, reading or watching videos.
You have to be knowledgeable about this.
Communication is the number
one most important thing
that is just the way people
decide at the end of the day.
I think that first it starts
with that, but my preference
is always internal.
People always laugh
that I give that advice
because I have a company, but it's better.
Like why pay a vig if you can do it?
I think the problem is this
skill specifically, the reason
people are struggling is
it's such a valuable skill,
usually people leave.
And so that's why they've
gone with agencies,
but I would definitely not
work with a publicly traded.
If it's owned by one of the
holding companies, you're dead.
That I've learned very obviously
because they're trying to make margin.
They're publicly traded.
So if there's an agency you're
working with but it ladders
up to WPP or Omnicon, you're finished
because they're gonna spend
your media to make the most
margin for themselves, not for you.
- [Man] What I'm hearing
you saying is that thing
we're talking about earlier
is that it's more from
the planning to doing in a
way so it's more tactical
and just being all over
the place in a way.
Am I correct, am I hearing you right?
- You know, it's funny.
You're hearing it right.
I find it fun, it makes me
smile, people think what it is
is all over the place,
throwing things on the wall,
schizophrenic, you know what I mean?
I think it's practical.
To me, it's practical.
But I understand why it
feels all over the place
because it's not the way,
you know, it feels different,
but to me, it makes sense.
For example, in America
I do this all the time.
If you're trying to sell
something to an African American
family, it's a good idea
to have African Americans
in the video.
That's what TV doesn't do.
Like, why can't you guys
make a video of two sisters
going to the store and
then targeting like women
that have sisters?
It's a lack.
I will promise you this,
if they spend 20 hours each
and actually understood
what Facebook actually does
and how it actually works,
you would never debate it
any other way.
It's literally the lack of
education that is holding back
organizations from it.
Or other financial rational
like your agency partners
coming in and showing bullshit
data because they can't
make as much margin on Facebook
as they can on television.
- [Man] I think you just
blew our registry hours.
- [Man] You haven't touched
on the SEO or anything.
- Yeah I mean to me, SEO is table stakes,
like it's important.
You should have it there,
but as you can see like even
my energy.
To me, a couple things with
SEO: one, it's on its last
half because voice is gonna kill it.
Like search is going to
be completely dismantled
by voice over the next decade.
That doesn't have anything to
do with what you care about
with sales the next
year and the next year.
But when you have 95% brand
awareness, if you do as you say,
to me, search is not the
place where you're gonna get
pay dirt.
You're probably spending some there.
You're probably organically
doing your thing at some level.
It's not the buying behavior of what I see
with pizza consumption
globally, or other things.
What you need, is back to his
point, you need a perception
change on that 95%, or promotional oomph.
As you said earlier...
- [Man] The search will
go voice then we won't...
- You'll be in deep shit.
- Then Facebook ads
will either be really, really good.
- No, I think what Facebook is
is passive content consumption.
You said it right.
Search is intent based marketing.
It's intent.
When I can say Alexa, send me a pizza.
This is why I want you to build a brand
because the next thing,
again, I don't know how long
your whole, again, I'm trying
to be very business here,
but if you're holding this
on for a while, or when no
no pizza, it sounds like
especially when you're starting it
and you're going global,
in seven years, when across
the globe people are saying
"Google, send me a pizza,"
they better say "Google,
send me a no pizza."
Because if they say
"Google, send me a pizza,"
it's either going to cost
you a fortune for the lead
gen ad, or Amazon is
gonna own a pizza company,
or have a private label.
There's a lot there.
- [Man] All of them probably.
- All of it, all of it.
Which is why building brand matters.
My concern is based on the
way you're spending media
and based on having the
assumption of 95% awareness,
I don't think your brand is
contextual, or is contemporary
as you think it is to
the seven to ten most
meaningful segmentations
that drive your business.
That would be my intuition
with the limited data
that I have.
More importantly, what I
love is it doesn't cost
a lot to go out and learn it and try it.
The thing that you're not
gonna like is the creative cost
against it.
The media in a year, you'll
be blown away by the media
efficiency and your world
is gonna go upside down
instead of 80% of media, 20 on creative.
You're gonna start
realizing it's more 50/50.
The scary part is you
have the math to show that
of the 50%, 80% isn't gonna
work, which is gonna fuck
with everybody here that cares about math,
but what you don't see is
that the 20% of that 50%
done right pays for all of it.
- [Man] I need to ask one more question.
What about the people not using Facebook
but just using messenger?
- So messenger, that's a great question.
Thank you for asking that.
I think messenger is a really
important place for you
to look at because you can
use AI and probably supplement
that enormous amount of what you're doing
from the ordering and the app standpoint.
I think messenger's an incredible product.
- That's what we have started.
- It's great.
- But I'm talking
about advertising.
How do you go about
heading into like again,
how do you spend 500
thousand on messenger?
- I wouldn't because I
don't think you can yet.
- [Man] Yeah exactly
but that's the question.
More Facebook usage going
down, prices going up.
- But it's not yet.
To your point, we'll worry
about that when it happens.
To me, I'm not worried about 2020.
It's why I even hesitate, yeah.
- [Man] In one year, yeah.
- I said it earlier, I'm unemotional.
If you told me Facebook
and Instagram and Twitter
are gone tomorrow, I'm like cool.
Where did everyone go?
- Last question I think.
- [Man] Is it yours?
(laughing)
- (mumbling) because we
juggle a lot of food concepts.
As we speak about food,
we live and breathe.
What's your take on the future for food?
- I think the customer is
disproportionally educated
and I think that is the only
thing I would spend time on.
My business partner, Steve Ross, is worth
14 billion dollars.
He bought into Michael Cheng, Danny Meyer.
I own a company called Resy,
R-E-S-Y, which is a global
leader in this space.
This space, I'm very fascinated by.
Here's my punchline:
number one, if you follow
current trends, you'll always lose.
So for example, if you said
to me Gary, you've been
adopted by us, and now I've
moved here and I live here
and now I have to open up one,
the company that I would be
working on right now with
the team is something
that is not healthy.
I think what you need to
think about is the customer
knows everything, but
all customers don't need
the same things.
So I think we're all
going down the same path
of healthy this, that,
and the other thing,
which creates supply and demand.
It's the way to think about marketing.
In a world that's very
complicated and we have
all these issues, it's
been very fun for me
in the last year to watch
mothers care a little less
if their kids having
something unhealthy to eat
in a world where they're
worried about racism and bombs.
It's funny how we get
caught in our current.
If I told you anything as
you're thinking about concepts,
it gets very easy to get
seduced by the current trend
without realizing that
in four and a half years
that ball has moved and
that if you actually look
at the data, the amount
of unhealthy food consumed
to the amount of healthy
food is not even close
and more importantly, can
you kind of take ownership
of indulgence, or escapism.
I would say escapism with food
is very interesting to me.
Which is like it's okay to have a sundae.
As a matter of fact, it's a good idea.
Stuff like that rings true to me.
Everyone is trying to do salads
and kale and fucking vegan
and that's great.
By the way, it will continue to grow.
But everybody's going there.
- [Man] Quadruple bacon on sundaes.
(laughing)
- I think his point is
the one that, you know,
it's always dangerous to
do a focus group of one,
but I will say this,
if you ask me on paper
what's probably happening,
that is a lot more real
than you'd like to understand.
Especially in the face of success.
It's where the opportunity is.
I think the biggest thing
is your communication
is missing a lot of people
because it's blunt objects.
It's like why the US struggled in Vietnam.
If you drop bombs, but everyone's hiding,
you're not getting them.
That's how I think this is.
You have to go...
- On the ground.
- Yes.
And again, the key and I'll say it again,
it's the framework my whole
company is gonna work on.
It's a kind of mix of the
old world, my old world,
that's what I grew up
with, and the new world.
You sit and say how many groups matter?
College kids, people of 40 thousand income
because it's a low cost food.
You just keep writing every
group and then you look at it
and you go okay, we've written 38 groups.
People that like sports.
It could be psychological, it
could be women, it could be
demographics, it could be
29 to 34-year-old women.
You just write them all that
you know and then you decide
how many are actually meaningful.
So you have 49 of them,
you get it down to six,
and then you make two, three
videos for each of them.
That is a very fertile opportunity
for you in this market.
- [Man] So that's the
recipe for the next double.
- [Man] And we have
the video star already.
- We do.
- At no extra cost.
- I'm telling you, I would use him.
I would use him.
Because one of the other reasons I'm here
is entrepreneurship is a very...
Unlike other places like
let's say Southeast Asia
where it's outwardly on a
pedestal, it's very intriguing
to me the psychology of the Nordics.
Entrepreneurship is on a
huge pedestal, just quiet.
So I think...
- What was the most
amazing thing that you saw today?
- I just literally flew in,
slept, and came right here.
So I haven't seen much.
- Okay.
- I saw enormous amounts of
happiness on the citizens' faces
because of the weather.
The most amazing thing so far.
But I think he's a bigger
asset and I think you won't
put him on a commercial,
but if you make a video
targeting 25 to 35-year-old
fans of entrepreneurship,
especially if you told the
truth, the truth, the truth...
- [Man] And recorded his life,
to me, I'm like shit, okay.
The change.
- 100%.
(people talking over each other)
- [Man] And made his life
as opposed to quoting pizza.
They always are like wow,
they're actually doing stuff
instead of like, I can
see when you spend money.
- 100% it would work.
Especially if you address
something with truth.
I don't know what.
Something, you know?
I wouldn't go like
everybody's a criminal route.
It's not about the competition,
I would take it insular
and there's something absolutely there.
Or, ask a question.
Again, Facebook and Instagram
ads, 25 to 35-year-old male
I would do the first one.
People that are into entrepreneurship.
If he just said "hey, with
technology now I can listen.
"What do you want from us?
"What can we do?"
You just get free fucking content.
You'll get free feedback.
They'll feel a part of it.
Then if you guys did one
thing that everybody said,
one thing, this music,
this color, this wallpaper,
this influencer to show up
at a store, and you showed
that you listened.
Watch how I'm doing it.
So if he did that, you got
comments, then you make